on the l word and Will & Grace to Paris
is burning and The Birdcage there are so
many TV shows and films featuring lgbtq+
characters and since miss Rona is
keeping us all inside what better time
than now to cue up some of our old and
new favorites joining me now to discuss
et's pics of what to stream this pride
is our very own stream Queen and our TV
expertly and Aguilera love in the
rainbow girl Thank You Danny happy pride
bu boo how you doing love to celebrate a
lot to watch - there's so much to stream
these days and as you know we DT love to
surround ourselves with pop culture
junkies so we went ahead and pulled all
of our co-workers and asked them to
reveal their favorite pics and that
here's what they had to say so this
pride I'm going to revisit Madonna's
truth or dare
[Music]
it was the first time as a kid even
though it's way too young to be watching
this
Thank You mom that I saw gay men
portrayed in a positive light and you
know it kind of showed that if you
follow your dreams you could end up on
tour with Madonna and Madonna is one of
the original gay allies I think a lot of
people try to erase what the work she's
done she spoke out about the AIDS crisis
before it was the popular thing to do
she really cares about it
we cannot celebrate Pride Month and
streaming content without talking about
shits Creek and the impact of shits
Creek David Rose was one of the first
openly pansexual characters on
television and gave us one of the
greatest explainers of all time I do
drink red wine but I also drink white
wine and I've been known to sample the
occasional Rose a and a couple summers
back I tried a merlot that used to be a
Chardonnay which got a bit complicated a
yeah so you're just really open to all
wines I like the wine and not the label
now what's cool about this scene is that
Emily Hampshire who plays Stevie who's
in the scene did not know what
pansexuality was prior to the show and
now years later uses this metaphor as a
way to explain her own pansexuality 35
months I always have to rewatch one of
my favorite movies GBF it Stanford I
know what it stands for gay best friend
my future GBF is just waiting to come
out of the closet tell me how fierce I
am it follows a high schooler Michael J
Willett who comes to town with his
sexuality and realizes up at other
cliques in high school are treating them
differently because he's gay it's sort
of like a gaming girls
so faction one of the things that really
resonates with me about the movie is
just how it doesn't take itself too
seriously it lets you look back at those
awkward moments with your parents or
tense decisions and lets you laugh at
them do you not call me that I meant
like girl with you right now
I can't get enough of a sex education on
Netflix I'm worried about you man
everybody's I was thinking about
shagging about to shine
will actually shaggy the show doesn't
seem to shy away from characters of all
race sexual orientation and gender z'
and mixing it up and it's not afraid to
ask questions and it's not afraid to be
a little silly and I'm just loving it go
talk to her she's got a really cute
smile Amy too knows how many girls are
gonna be up your vagina next year one of
the films that I watched recently was
both smart and I thought it was a great
film because it took place in 2019 and I
just feel like kids today are way more
accepting of being an LGBTQ than they
were when I was growing up right what
there's a big plot point in the film
where what Kaitlyn Dever is character is
having her first lesbian experience and
I just thought that was really cool
because it wasn't the biggest plot point
but it wasn't so overlooked and I just
loved how gracefully they handled that
so apparently there's a million single
people in Chicago
I don't do the casual one-night thing
very well free forms the thing about
Harry which is actually the first queer
rom-com in TV movie history this movie
has everything it has romance friendship
humor it is so good and you are in for a
treat I actually got to sit down with
the stars Jake and Nico recently in our
et studios and this is what they had to
say discussing why this historic movie
is so important one of the the biggest
parts of why I was so excited about the
movie is that Sam he's not only queer
he's super into politics he wants to use
his queerness to change the world to
make the world a better place
I'm excited Leanne because there's a lot
of new LGBTQ projects coming down the
pipeline oh my gosh tiny so many good
new ones the one that I'm most excited
about right now is love Victor and that
is a new TV series coming to Hulu and it
is set in the exact same world as love
Simon and it follows a young high school
freshman in the same high school who's
trying to navigate his world and coming
out when it's not so much of a
picture-perfect ideal setting it is so
sweet it's got so much heart I cannot
wait for you to see it Mike
wait because also prompts to Hulu this
features a queer person of color ok so
props all around I can't wait for that
it is so amazing but if Deni if you are
looking for even more things to stream
this June do not worry because there are
brand new episodes of stream Queens
premiering each week on eg live with new
episodes on Thursdays that's right can't
wait thanks Lee Anne thanks Denny happy
bride
[Music]